hello and welcome to this british
council webinar
on how to apply to uk universities
this is a second in a series of webinars
we've been giving
the last one was why applied to uk
universities
and that's available on our website
i my name is george wilson and i run our
university preparation section here at
the british council
we'll talk about that a little bit more
later on
uh for now though let's move straight
into
a recap of the very good reasons why
we should apply to the uk next slide
please
so there are several reasons why the uk
is one of the world's premium
study destinations first of all
you're guaranteed a warm welcome the uk
is a highly multicultural
society and the higher education sector
is a good example of that
in 2017-18
there were 143 000 eu
students studying in the uk
and that's only a fraction of the wider
international student
body which numbered 485
000 international students
what's more a quarter of the uk's
teaching staff
come from different countries which
helps really create a good exchange of
ideas
and that in turn feeds into the quality
of our teaching so the uk is world
renowned for the quality of its
universities
there are uh
28 of the top 200 universities in the
world
are in the uk some of them you can
probably name
cambridge oxford but there are many many
more
world-beating universities that i would
strongly encourage you to look into
the student satisfaction rates in the uk
are
excellent ninety percent of
international students
feel that it was a beneficial choice for
them to go to the uk
and that it helped them and many of them
feel it helped them
in their careers later on
speaking of careers surveys show that
the uk produces some of the most
employable
graduates in the world and you can be
sure that by
investing in a uk education you're
really getting the best
career prospects on the job market
whether it be in the uk
or abroad but more than that university
is a social event in the uk
people don't tend to live at home they
tend to go
to live in their universities that might
be in a hall of residence
it might be in a shared flat or it might
be in a private home
with other students now
this creates a unique kind of blend of
people
all tasting their independence for the
first time
the result is that you have a vibrant
social life
involving societies associations in
other words
such as french societies cocktail
societies
chess societies and so on
but you also have sports club theater
groups all sorts that
enable people to really get the most out
of their university experience
next slide please the result of all that
is that the uk really attracts a huge
number
of people from france in 19 in 2019
there were 5 575 applicants
to uk universities and we're very
hopeful that that will continue
with people like you france was the
country that sent the most
students to the uk in the eu
next slide please
now let's after this quick resume
of the reasons to study in the uk which
you can find more information about
on our previous webinar um
let's look at just some of the practical
information
about studying in the uk in a
post-brexit
situation the uk university
system is still wide open to
international students
and yes the rules have changed a little
but not dramatically
so if you begin your studies after the
31st of july
2021 you will now be paying
international student
fees now these fees can vary between
eleven thousand
and thirty thousand pounds per year
however
each university fixes the fee and it
varies according to the subject so if
you're studying
a subject that costs more for the
university
then it will be more expensive than if
you're studying one
which is cheaper for the university
if you're a uk citizen and you begin
your course in the next few years
you won't have to pay these fees you'll
pay home student fees
which are cheaper if you are
um living in the uk already
you won't have to pay these fees
so one way around this slight increase
in fees
is to explore the different scholarships
and bursaries
which universities offer at the moment
to help you uh make the right choices
and help you with the finance necessary
to carry those through
towards the end of this presentation
i'll share with you some
useful links where you can have a look
at different
bursary schemes and so on
next slide please
you'll also need of course now to have a
visa
if you arrive after the 1st of january
2021
and your course lasts for more than 6
months
you'll need a visa now that visa will be
delivered for the duration of your
course
it will cost 348 pounds and all you'll
need is a valid travel document
and of course an offer from a university
in fact it will be so easy you'll be
able to use a smartphone app
to complete the process uh
you'll need in addition to your visa to
pay
the equivalent of a french mutual so
a immigration health surcharge
that will be 470 pounds at the moment
per year
that charge will give you access to our
nhs our national health service and will
enable you to make sure that you're well
cared for if ever you fall ill
once you've got your offers and we'll
talk about that later on
you can apply for your visa applications
open on the 5th of october
but you can only apply up to 6 months
before the beginning of the course
now you might wonder what will happen at
the end of your course
luckily there's a new scheme called the
graduate route
and this will give you the opportunity
to work in the uk
for two years post
your studies post studies so once you
finish you'll be able to stay for two
years and gain valuable experience in
the uk
and give back to the uk industries that
you've been learning from
there's lots of information about all
this on various
websites but notably the new immigration
system is
explained on the british government's
web page
and on our study uk moving to the uk
pages those links are on the bottom of
this slide
next slide please
now that was the detailed information
about
why and changes to the system
but the application process hasn't
changed so let's look in detail now
at the real subject of our webinar today
how to apply
to the uk now
all the applications for uk universities
go via a website and an organization
known as ucas this is a non-profit
organization
which means that they're just there to
help you
they have no interest in
doing anything but helping you make the
right choices for you
it's a really simple process and we're
going to look a little
at the stages of that today
um there it's also possible to contact
you guests if you have any questions
they're very accessible and i'll give
you their phone number
a little later on if you have any
questions at any point please do
feel free to write in the chat and we'll
get back to you at the end
next slide please so
ucas will help you gain access to one of
the 370
universities and colleges in the uk
of course the uk is made up of different
countries
england scotland wales and northern
ireland
and you can see from this slide that the
vast majority of universities
are in england but there are some
excellent ones in other areas of the uk
as well how many courses a huge
number thousands and thousands
and that means that the next important
stage
when you're or the first important stage
and the most important stage
is research next slide please
so to begin your process begin your
study
adventure you need to begin by doing
research
you can begin with the ucas search tool
this is on their website and it lets you
search by entry requirements
search by university search by course
and probably discover courses you never
even imagined could exist
for example in the uk there are many
combinations of different subjects
that can be really eye-opening
you might want to do criminology in
french or
textiles and astrophysics
these courses are possible in the uk
because of our system
of joint honors joint honours means that
you do half of one degree
and half of another and it comes
together to make 100
of a degree you might also want a major
minor
where you do more of one subject and
less of another
these are possible combinations that let
you really
tailor your course to you so it's really
important to look in detail at the
courses
look in detail at the universities to
help you do that
there are open days and virtual tours on
the website
that you can take advantage of
there are also some salon in france
where university prevent
presents their courses now obviously at
the moment that's a bit tricky
but a british council has found some
solutions and i'll show you
those in a moment you can also look at
videos and blogs and learn
from other students and lots of those
are available
on the ucas website next slide please
so you can see the research tool here on
your screen
it's really easy to use and i could
strongly recommend that you spend a lot
of time
really thinking hard notably
in my experience lots of french people
go for
a handful of uk universities
i think they're the ones that people
know best
but it's not necessarily the best
university for you so really
think widely open your mind and do a lot
of research into different universities
and different areas next
slide please so
make some careful choices let's look at
some of the criteria
that should be guiding you in this
process next parts please
enjoyment career path these are
important
so my own guiding principle was that i
really needed to enjoy
what i was studying now obviously that's
personal but i think it's a good rule of
thumb that if you enjoy something you're
going to do better at it
think about your career path as well now
the uk
job market is a bit different to the
french one in the sense that
you can often try a different area
that not directly related to your degree
for example i studied english in french
i'm an english and french teacher but i
could
have gone into business i could have
gone into law
i could have gone into journalism these
different options
are wide open at the end of a degree in
the uk because we work on the principle
of transferable skills
so think about where you want to work
and think about the best degree for you
to achieve that
talk to employers talk to universities
write to their admission department
ask for statistics about where they go
after they finish their degrees
the location we talked a little about
this do you want to be on a campus in
the countryside with
everything centralized then maybe
universities like warwick are for you
do you want to be living in a city with
one building
dispersed here and there and over there
then maybe ucl is for you it depends
very much on
type of layout of university
and how where you want to be there are
universities that have colleges
like durham or cambridge or oxford in
which case you apply
to a college and you can and that they
handle the admission process for you as
you join the university
so research on the websites of the
universities notably
some information about what structure
what form that university
takes next part please
study style so we talked a little about
the different
courses but think also about whether
you're going to thrive
with a very independent study style
the uk has is very different in this
regard to france
there are far fewer contact hours in
many degrees
so for example with my degree in english
and french
i had about seven hours a week of
contact but i had a lot of work
i worked very hard but it was self
study it was reading books it was
writing essays
it was preparing presentations and i did
a lot of that at home
or in the library so it's all a bit
different
and you need to think will i thrive in
that situation
look at individual courses ask how
they're assessed
ask how many contact hours is
questioning
questioning questioning at this stage
next please we talked about the
extracurricular activities
do you want to do rowing in which case
you need to be near a river
do you want to go to a university with a
wonderful
theater society these could be guiding
principles for you
as well next slide please
oh sorry one more last point of course
you need to look into the bursaries
you need to look into the scholarships
and the fees
for your new courses okay
next you also want to choose a
university that's
well ranked in the different rankings
that are out there
so to give you an idea of how good the
university will be for you
there are lots of different criteria on
these websites
you can look at uni stats or times
higher education
rankings but be careful
just because a university is well ranked
doesn't mean it's well ranked for your
subject
so make sure you search by subject make
sure you compare
the rankings for your subject
there are other different uh criteria
that can be taken into account
for example the guardian people and
planets ranking
shows the sustainability of the
university what
impact it has on the environment so if
that's something important for you
then that ranking is a good guide
there's also the government's teaching
excellence framework
that enables universities to receive a
different
award gold silver bronze depending on
how
well they've they doing in terms of
research
and teaching so that's a very useful
guide for you
as well next slide please
we spoke before about the open days and
the virtual tours
so you can see here this is what the
website looks like
and if we click again you can see
the different sections available to you
yes thank you so you can see you click
on exhibitions and open days
and it will take you to that section
okay
next british council of france of course
is here to help you
so we have uh what's going on paige an
events
page on our website and on there you can
find useful webinars like this one
next please but
we also have an online fair which will
be running
from the 19th of october to the 13th of
november
our objective is to help you connect
with university specialists
with individual universities and with
advisors like me
so you can take an appointment to speak
one-to-one
with one of 40 uk universities
you can take an appointment to speak to
me or one of my colleagues
and we'll give you advice about the
process of applying
you can also attend online talks with
universities
and different specialists they'll talk
about subjects
fees applications visas and much more
so to register i put the link up here
and i strongly encourage you to take
advantage of this situation
it's a wonderful opportunity to have
access to a huge number
of uk universities and ask them directly
the questions you might have thank you
next slide so the application itself
the application is entirely online in
most situations
you make a maximum of five choices
now if you're applying to um dentistry
to veterinary science or to medicine
that's only four
there are some choice restrictions for
example if you're applying to oxford
you can't apply to cambridge if you have
liked cambridge you can't apply to
oxford
so there are a few factors to take into
account but
generally it's five choices
and we'll come on to how um on to what
to do with those
afterwards there's a simple application
cost that's really not very expensive
and as long as you meet the deadlines
you'll be given equal consideration
that means that the university promises
to read your application
like it would anyone else's if you miss
the deadlines
they might well read it but they're not
obliged to
okay that's a different rule so if you
want to be sure the university will read
and treat your universe
your application equally then make sure
you apply by the deadlines
there's also invisibility in the
application procedure
so if i apply to coventry university
and sheffield university and cambridge
university
they don't know which universities i've
applied for
they only know that i've applied to them
to the specific university
next slide please
so when you go on to do the application
you can see there are six sections
the first one are the personal details
be really careful with this
thousands of people make mistakes with
their name
with details like their criminal record
so be really careful to read it and
check it carefully
then you have your choices which we
spoke about
uh you complete your education section
on the form
now education is anything that you've
got an official grade
for so if you do you're back
in french in the in premiere by the time
you apply
you'll be able to put in that grade on
there
employment likewise employment is only
things you've been paid to do
you'll have a chance to talk about
volunteering and work experience
but employment is what you've been paid
to do so for someone like me
it would be a lot longer than a 17 year
old an 18 year old
and that's quite normal there's no
problem with that
then with your personal statement which
we'll come back to
and your referee now your referee
should probably be one of the teachers
in your school
the reference needs to be in english and
however the teacher can talk to all the
other teachers
and compile um
some information about you that gives a
thorough overview of your
skills in all the other subjects it's
better if it's a teacher
because they're in a better position to
have an overview
of your academic achievements
next slide please
so when we uh yeah thank you we'll come
back to the referee in a moment
so when to apply applications open on
the 6th of september
they close for most people
on the 15th of january so
after that you can still put in an
application but they
they're not obliged to treat it equally
with the others
they probably will they might anyway but
there's certainly no guarantee
now if you're applying to oxford or
cambridge
and most courses in medicine dentistry
or veterinary science
then you need to apply by the 15th of
october
now be careful when you when i say apply
you do need to submit your own
application
but your referee also needs to have
validated it
needs to have sent their part so you
need to not
do it on the last moment at the last
moment because when you
enter the referee's details they
get an email and they have to upload
their reference
once they've done it your application is
complete okay
um yeah applications close
on the 30th of june so at that point you
really can't submit an application in
the traditional way
however we'll see that there are other
ways in which you can apply to uk
university
even after the 30th of june and right
into october
next slide please
so let's dwell a little on the personal
statement let's talk a little about what
this
short text has as a role
in your application so it's the only
section that the applicant has control
over
it's your only chance to market yourself
now you only make one you only write one
personal statement
for all of your choices so
what does that mean it means if i'm
applying to
english at sheffield french at saint
andrews
um english and french at nottingham
that's fine it's quite easy for my
personal statement to reflect those two
subjects
however if i'm applying for mathematics
at one university for physics there's
another
and for theater that's another
it becomes quite difficult to make a
coherent personal statement
that covers all of those possibilities
so think about what you want to do make
choices that enable you to write a
personal statement
that's coherent and logical
so it's a maximum of four thousand
characters
make sure you check on the website it's
not always the same as microsoft word
uh it's about 47 lines and there's a
minimum
of 1 000 characters however you don't
need to worry too much about the minimum
because you'll have lots to say there's
no spelling or grammar check on the
website
make sure you check it carefully make
sure you put it through a spell check on
word
or some other um piece of software
you can write it as one big paragraph
because it all gets combined
however it's important that it's
structured so my advice would be to
write separate paragraphs
even if then they get conflated into one
on the system next slide please
what are they looking for they're
looking for you to show that you have
independent study skills so think about
what have you read
what have you done how have you proved
to people
that in fact you have what it takes to
go to the library every day
to be in to have an inquiring mind
to do research that will show
independence of thought
self-awareness motivation
you've got to want it you've got to show
that you want it
show that you've got an understanding of
the course there's no point applying for
biology if you
don't know anything about biology so
it's important you show that
numeracy and literacy so make sure there
are no mistakes
research skills show that you have
researched the university you've
researched the subject
you know something about it they're
obviously checking your essay writing
by this short mini essay they want to
see that you're enthusiastic
that you really really really want to go
to their university
and they want to show that you can
manage your time and that you have
reflective thinking skills that you're
aware of where you
are going and that you're aware of
the challenges and the exciting
things that will come up on that journey
next slide please
so here are our top tips um
make sure you've got a strong opening
paragraph
be careful if you say i've always wanted
to be a vet
it's not true you were a child it's a
cliche
avoid that kind of cliche interest
people
lots of people ask me if they can write
quotes in their opening paragraph
there's no rule against it and if you
can show why you're doing it
maybe but be aware of the fact that you
don't have very many words
to really sell yourself so make sure
your voice is what they hear
they don't need to hear socrates so
think carefully about and be discerning
with any quotes you choose to use
research the courses know why you're
applying where you're applying what it's
like
as a general rule make it about eighty
percent
academic and twenty percent
extracurricular
that's your chance to talk about things
like volunteering
to talk about um
different experiences that have shaped
who you are today travel
your knowledge of the uk and all of that
but yeah the 80
academic talk about things like um
the projects you've done at school the
extra reading you've done
why you're interested in that subject
what it is about that subject
that appeals to you but be honest
there's no point writing things that are
not true
in some universities you'll have
interviews so it's best not to try your
luck with anything that's
too exaggerated or untrue
now you can't write this in a day on our
courses at british council we help
people
by giving them advice on personal
statements but this process goes on for
a month
a month and a half sometimes it's slow
and it's
it requires you to write to think to
look at it again another day
to show it to somebody and ask them
is this me have i properly shown a good
picture of myself
or do you not recognize me you want to
be presenting a good picture of yourself
so make sure it really reflects who you
are
now it's really important to notice that
there's no perfect
personal statement the clue is in the
word
personal you can look online and you'll
see lots of examples
but they're not the right example for
you i've spoken to many recruitment
officers
in my life and those recruitment
officers
know if you didn't write it they know if
it's something that's been
lightly modified from the internet or if
a counselor
wrote it for you or an agent
so my strong advice is yes get somebody
to check the english
make sure it's okay but don't change it
all
to reflect what an adult or
a friend or a counselor or the internet
suggests you should have in your
personal statement
what it should be is personal to you
next slide please
so that's the personal statement but the
next key point i'd like us to look at
is the reference so it's an essential
part of the application
as we said it should be like one of your
teachers
and it must discuss your academic
performance
so some of my students will ask me can
you be my referee
and i can't not very easily because i
don't
know yes if they're applying for english
i can talk about english
but i can't talk about chemistry so it
should be
a teacher giving an overview of the
relevant
subjects and overall achievement
make sure you give your personal
statement to the referee
it's actually really hard writing a good
reference
so you need to give them all the
information that you can
to help make sure they know where you're
going and how they can help you get
there
now we come to the slightly tricky part
the reference must include a predicted
grade for the overall baccalaureate
now that's something that doesn't really
exist in france
and it's but in the uk it's it's very
well it's
normal all students will receive a
predicted grade
now that grade is what will really
determine
if you're able to apply to a certain
university and if you're accepted
so it's really really important
so talk to your teacher make sure that
they're not being
over generous but they're not being
unreasonably
harsh either explain to them the
importance
of this grade it's also a chance for you
to talk about any anomalies
in your or sorry for the referee to talk
about any anomalies
in your studies so
if people often ask me my school marks
particularly
harshly so in that case the referee can
talk about that
and so on it needs to be in english
so make sure although you're not they're
not being judged on their english
it must be easy to read so they can
work together with an english teacher
for example
okay next slide please
sometimes you need to do extra exams and
those can be organized
usually in paris or in france i should
say
so you need to investigate that once
you've submitted your application
the university will get back to you and
ask you to complete the different exams
sometimes you have interviews notably
for durham oxford cambridge
but some others as well those interviews
are an opportunity for them to really
see if you fit
with the college or the university
you've applied to
so we can talk more about preparing that
um by reading the different blog posts
that are on the british council website
next slide please and of course
often you'll need to do some kind of
test or exam
to prove your english level not always
sometimes the university will make an
offer
where they accept that your
baccalaureate was very good
sometimes if you've done an
international baccalaureate an igcc
so these qualifications can count
likewise if you've done a cae
or a cpe exam an advanced english or
proficiency exam
with cambridge that can sometimes count
but often very often the university will
make you an offer
which includes um getting a certain
score on the baccalaureate
but also a certain score on ielts
ielts is the international english
language testing system
and it's run in by the university of
cambridge
the british council and an australian
university together
once you do the test which you can do
with us
in in paris or elsewhere in france
it's valid for two years it should be
valid when you arrive
at the university so make sure you time
it
carefully you get a score
from one to nine and this is a
photograph of your english level it's
not the test
it's not the british council that's
saying this is past or this is
fail the university will say you need to
get
six seven on on an
overall score and therefore
you need to be working on your english
to make sure you get that score
um they might also ask for a specific
skill in writing
so be careful look carefully at what
they're asking
and work hard to get that we run
online sorry we run courses during the
holidays
on preparing students for the ielts test
and we also incorporate it into our
university preparation courses
now this test although it's a photograph
of your english level
does require you to have some exam
technique
to be familiar with the the tricks of
the test to make sure that you know
um what that is expected of you
just like any test so i strongly
recommend
if you do need to do it
you buy a book you look on the internet
you do some research into what's
expected of you in each part of the test
or even better you do a thorough
training course with us
in france you can book your tests online
on the british council website
okay next slide please
so application advice as i said before
our blog
has lots and lots of articles on it
which are an opportunity
for you to read all about
different elements of applying including
the personal statement there are some
wonderful articles on there
written by advisors and recruitment
specialists
next slide please
so you've done your application you've
submitted it before the deadline
and this is what happens next you can
track your application
you can track it using what's called
track
it's a part of the ucas website it will
tell you
what what's happening with your
application all stages of the process
so you can see whether you've been made
whether you've been made
offers and you can see
you can reply to your offers so
as a result it's really actually very
easy
to follow through the process and see
clearly where you are and what you need
to do
by when so as soon as you create your
space on the website you'll have access
to this and be able to submit your
application and follow it
next slide please it looks a bit like
this
to give you an idea next slide
please
so you've submitted your application
what happens next the universities will
get back to you
they will get back to you they have to
but they can
give three answers they can say that you
are
unsuccessful and that they're not going
to give you a place
they can say that you are successful
as long as you get
13 on the baccalaureates 12 in english
and i score a 6. it depends
that's known as an as a conditional
offer
but they might make you an unconditional
offer
an unconditional offer means that
whatever grade you get they really
really want you
and you'll be able to go to that
university
even if you were to fail all your
subjects
now obviously the most common of these
is the conditional offer
an unconditional offer is often made to
people
like me i guess who have already done
their qualifications
and have the paper already so there's no
point making me a conditional offer
because i've got the certificate i can
just show it to them
so when you get all your decisions
all your offers i should say you can
choose two offers
one of them is a firm choice and one
is an insurance choice if you want to
so the firm choice is the one that you
will go to
if you get the grades they're asking for
if you don't you'll telephone them and
check
if you can still go they might say yes
often they do
but if they don't you've made an
insurance choice
probably one that was asking for lower
grades
and as a result you'll be able to go to
this insurance choice
and they will accept you as long as they
you got the grades
they asked for as soon as you've made
those choices
you enter them on track and all the
other offers
are declined that's the end for them
you don't have to apply until reply
until you've got
all the offers on the table so when all
the offers are on the table
you can make your choices and
um make them knowing what was on what
was possible
track will show you the reply date you
need to to reply by
um once all the offers have been given
to you
next slide
now let's say that you don't get the
grades
it's not the end of the world many many
many
get into university every year in the uk
through
clearing which begins in early july and
continues all the way up into october
so if you apply after the 30th of june
or if you receive no offers or if you
decline
all your offers you change your mind or
you didn't get the grade
then you use this part of the website to
ask universities can i come anyway
and this huge number of people get
accepted every year
through this process of clearing
you also have a couple more options
let's imagine
that you used all five choices but
nobody
made you an offer or you declined all
the offers you didn't want them
you can add extra choices one at a time
on track um so for example i might write
to one university and say
hello this is me here's my personal
statement
would you like me and if they say no
then i can write to a different one and
if they say no i can write to a
different one
it's a longer process but it's a good
way of getting around that situation
there's also one other situation a more
positive one
where you get your place with your firm
choice
but you did better than you expected
that enables you on track to ask other
universities with
who would have asked for higher grades
if you can go to that university so it's
quite rare
but it's nice to know it's there just in
case there's any
um pleasant surprises and you get really
good grades you didn't expect
next slide please
so that kind of resumes what uh students
can do
and should do to go about their
university application
how can parents help there's a section
on the ucas website with lots of extra
resources for you
as parents you can use that
to support your children and make sure
that you're
helping them in what really is a huge
decision
you can offer to attend open days or sit
in on
um online open days
you can make sure that you don't book
family holidays in the run up to the
deadlines
you can really make sure and double
check everything that's sent in
an extra pair of eyes is very welcome
and you might well want to talk to the
school
especially in france about the reference
and the predicted grade now that really
is good advice
because as i say many teachers have
never done this
and they need you to explain and talk it
through with them
and that's quite a lot to ask of a
student
next slide please as i said before
here's the phone number for ucas and you
can ring them up anytime
in those working hours and they're super
helpful
they'll give you the answer to any
question you might have
next slide this is
our website study uk which
is a fantastic resource of the most
up-to-date information what i'm saying
today may not be
valid in a month or two months time but
this website will always
be valid and up to date so it's a real
reference point for you in this process
thank you next slide here are some
useful websites and we'll send you the
powerpoint
so that you can look at them in your own
time
and next slide please and of course
the section we have at the british
council is called preparation for
university studies in english
not just in the uk but in the us canada
australia
or in france if you're going to study
a subject such as engineering or
hoteliery
you may well end up in a in a cursus
which is taught
in english and our section will help
prepare you for that
if you'd like to know more just go on to
our website
and book a placement test and from there
we can
orientate you towards the right course
next slide please and that brings me
to the end of this presentation we've
got some time for questions
so if you have any questions enter them
into the chat
uh nishma are you there all right
questions hello yes we do have quite a
few questions actually
um so i'm just gonna go through them uh
so the first question
it was it was much cheaper in scotland
is it still the case no unfortunately
it's not
it was much cheaper for european
citizens to go and study
in scotland in fact it was free in terms
of student fees
but that's changed so you need to look
at each individual university
individually and check what the fee for
that subject
in that university is
okay and the second question was can we
apply to more than
one course per university yes you can
you can apply to for example i think i
applied to
english and english in french in leeds
university
and you can still do that today
okay perfect so i keep muting myself
there's a lot of background noise sorry
about that
um okay so are there any specific
restrictions for students under 18
regarding university or jobs or training
that's an excellent question i think the
best thing to do in that situation
is to contact the university directly
and ask them if it's a problem if you'll
be under 18
when you come to the university i don't
think there's a policy on it on a uk
level
but there is probably a policy within
the university
it would also be worth looking at the
visa information website
where there'll be information about
whether you can apply for the visa
at what age and so on so that's on on
this powerpoint
and you'll be able to see it on the visa
page
perfect um okay so uh in order uh in
order to study business
which subject should i keep in my last
year of high school economics or maths
which is the most important
that's a really good question i think
that within
the uk system there's quite an open mind
to the subjects that you've studied
obviously if you want to be a doctor you
need to study biology i would imagine
but if you want to be a journalist or if
you want to be was it business
work in business they're going to look
at the skills you've accrued
not at the subject and title
as such that said the best person
to answer that question would be if you
contacted
a university you're interested in on the
web page you'll find their admissions
department
and just ask them that question and it's
a really interesting one because i think
the answer will probably be do well
but um it would be sensible just to
double check
okay um
all right so another question when do we
have to pay the fees if accepted in a
university is it possible to wait for
all answers before confirming one
specific admission
so there's two questions there i think
yes so yes
you you automatically wait for all the
answers
and then you're given a date in track
and you have to apply by that date
but that day until you until you've got
all the offers
and until that deadline all the
universities have to wait for
you to reply they can't change their
mind
and the other question about fees you
would you normally pay the fees towards
the beginning of the academic year
but it would be broken down into
installments probably over the years
okay um the next question which
uh phil thank you phil kindly replied
yes but um
can you have the referee statement
translated if the referee is french i'm
assuming the person fiona fiona's asking
whether they can translate it here in
france as opposed to whether the
university would
translate it the university won't
translate it
um you can have it translated but
it would need to be by certified that
would need to be
assembled in france um
you could however potentially have it
translated within the school
by an english teacher or somebody um
and then it would obviously be signed by
the school in the same way
and validated by the school in the same
way okay
um are the chances the same
uh so are the chances of your
of yeah other chances are the same
whether you submit your application in
october or january
um that's a good question yes in theory
they're the same you might start getting
offers
earlier if you submit it earlier but
yes i the idea is that you will be given
equal consideration until the 15th of
january
that said i should also point out that
you're in a really good position at the
moment
demographically there are not that many
18 year olds
in the uk compared to when i went to
university
as a result the universities are quite
generous they need you and they want you
so um yeah they'll give you equal
consideration
and quite often they'll be quite
generous at the moment
okay here's another question um does it
help to go to a summer school in a
university
in order to join that or be accepted by
that university
it helps in the sense that you need to
write about in your
personal statement it's kind of the
perfect uh
academic bit to add to your personal
statement and
if you are interested in that university
specifically then yes it's helpful um
but it's not guaranteed by any means
and remember when you apply you're
probably applying to five universities
so name checking one doesn't necessarily
mean that you will automatically
get that one
okay great um a couple more so
is igcse requested by
universities no it's not requested
as a prerequisite however it can
sometimes
be a dispensation from doing an ielts
test
for example sometimes it depends on the
individual department
in the individual university
um okay uh i think you covered this in
your presentation but just in case
um do you receive all the answers at the
same time
no you don't um in fact sometimes it can
be over a period of months
um but as i said when you get all the
answers when you've got all the answers
the kind of clock starts ticking and you
have a couple of weeks to make your
decision
until then they can't change their mind
even if they have to wait two months
after they sent you an offer
okay um how to choose a university
teaching hr
that's a really good question so you
would go onto the ucas website
you would start you would start looking
for
human resource subjects there may well
be a subject
called human resources if there isn't i
would contact
um an employer and
why would maybe contact a it depends
where you want to work in hr i guess in
france or in the uk or elsewhere
but i would do research contacting
employers etc
and ask them what qualifications they
require
in order to employ you i would imagine
there's probably some professional
qualifications you may need to do
afterwards as well
okay um and one last question
uh so applying for two courses
in one does applying for two courses in
one university count as one choice or
two choices
two choices good try
uh yes and that's everything so unless
wonderful
we have any other questions last minute
questions coming in
we've covered them all thanks george
well thank you very much everybody and
thank you nishma
it's wonderful to have this opportunity
to kind of stress
that the uk really is a wonderful
destination
for studying at higher education level
and that hasn't changed
so i strongly encourage you to take
advantage of our online
fair take advantage of
all the blogs and all the opportunities
you have to really
enter into contact with universities and
just
really make good choices so that when
you come to make your
to enter your application you're
confident you've made
the right choices for you george so i do
have one more that's just come in
um do uk universities prefer
an ib or oib
again the it doesn't make a difference
from the point of view of the academic
baccalaureate side of it
but it may well be that one would
dispense you
from an english uh test
in a certain university the universities
are really good the
admissions departments know what an oib
is
they know what an ib is they know what
an igcse is
it's kind of their their specialism so
as a result
they you'll have to wait really until
you get your offer
from the university to see if what
they've taken into account and then at
that point if needs be
you can book an ielts test
great thanks okay well thank you very
much everybody
it's been a pleasure and best of luck
thank you